my question for the Jonas Brothers is
did it feel so good taking off your
purity ring Miley Cyrus questions the
Jonas Brothers during their interview on
at Capitol breakfast and did it feel so
good taking off your purity right you
know as a time yeah
you might remember Miley Cyrus and Nick
Jonas actually dated from June 2006 to
December 2007 and inspired Miley's seven
things
[Music]
now back to those infamous purity ring's
where's your ring I don't necessarily
like to talk about the purity ring's but
the brothers did open up about their
rarely talked about jewelry on carpool
karaoke in March we were never gonna
talk about it because we're like you
know this is not really this is not
world the world's our own thing but of
course you have three young boys wearing
rings on their fingers it was like are
they married already
like what's going on in here happening
three rings were to wait for the right
person when the time was right and
here's the catch when you're like 12 and
you do that because we grew up in a
group of church sure and our dad faster
and so like kindness came natural for
everyone that we grew up with to go
through this and get one and say I'm
gonna wait for the right person some
people say wait till marriage
[Music]